the the truth is that um ron paul at the
time broke fundraising records uh bernie
sanders then came in and smashed those
yeah and they didn't do it by going to
private equity guys
on myspace 24 hours that's right that's
right ron paul yes it was and it broke
records and he didn't even set it up he
literally just got into the camera and
said things that people really
appreciated and so what i think is that
the role for libertarians here is that
we're not going to out-compete democrats
and republicans in terms of getting more
money from private equity or big banks
or something like that because we're not
offering them what democrats and
republicans are the truth is that if the
libertarian agenda were to ever be put
in place big banks would make way less
money than they make right now we're the
party who wants to abolish the federal
reserve and make sure there's never
banker bailouts again and that they
don't have unlimited access to easy
money and that they can you know like
yeah i bet if if i could borrow money at
zero percent interest rate and then loan
it out to the public uh for at four
percent i could do pretty good making
money too but we're trying to end that
scheme